[Music]
we always talk about overwatch being
about soldiers scientists adventures and
oddities Ariza evolves and pushes the
boundaries of what the overwatch
universe could be a lot of the
characters have overwatch come from many
different places sometimes is from
designs and dented from story sometimes
it starts with the art we talked a lot
about introducing another what we like
to call anchor tank Reinhard's well the
only characters that can really sort of
stand his ground and mark a spot and
move with his team real slow so we
thought it was great opportunity there
for another option arisa was amazing
almost from the earliest prototypes well
I was testing and iterating all these
ideas I was actually using one is
risible alternate skins internally to
make it so it wasn't soo confusing as
oreos in the game just we could test it
we see a gothic zaria adds to it
bastions cannon it was just a
combination of cobble together parts but
it was instantly fun and that's how we
knew we were onto a good hero
larissa she pretty quickly took on a
life of Rowan of course which is great
the look of orissa really spawned from
the idea of wanting to do it an African
mech we have the map konnen Bonnie which
is in Africa and in Bonnie being one of
the more futuristic cities we have in
overwatch with the curved shapes and
like the greens and yellows and earth
tones really wanted that to carry
through into erisa design one of the
things that we haven't done yet was a
quadruped head there's a whole ecology
of a mnemonic yunus-bek furlanic crisis
there are three legs four legs five legs
you name it so we wanted to kind of
explore what other archetypes overwatch
could have my name is OD Sam I would
keep you safe IRISA is the current
guardian of new Bonnie technically she's
like the youngest remember if you want
to say that she's kind of new to her
role as a hero and she doesn't really
know her place in the world yet she's
the creation of this brilliant
eleven-year-old engineer named effie she
wants this robot to protect her city and
I think once we saw that character it
really helped to cement like I get it
this is the girl who made this robot I
can see the Creator who built it and I
think that really helped the ring your
life
[Music]
we're sort of debuting her at a very
early state in her career as character
and I think will be interesting to watch
that progression hopefully we'll be able
to tell that story in one way or another
I think she's a core character in the
overwatch lineup in terms of gameplay
mechanics and functionality she kind of
has devoted to transform games and ways
that very few girls can she's gotta
serve a really unique role in overwatch
you
[Music]
you
you